we've got the Apple watch a series 5
right here if we're gonna unbox it and
test it out this is the gold aluminum
case in pink sand sport band and this is
the 40 millimeter version so in addition
to this one they also launched the new
titanium and a titanium black which both
looked really awesome I got a chance to
check those out at the Apple event
I personally ordered the ceramic one so
I'll probably be doing an unboxing of
that one as soon as it comes in for now
we have this pink aluminum one to check
out so let's just unbox this is always
so exciting unboxing a new Apple watch
their packaging is so thoughtful here it
is oh and here's all the new watches too
on their little packaging here it is
here's the watch band okay
this is so great are you ready oh even
has like a little pink little dust cover
on it too
oh wow okay now now maybe I want this
one super into the pink aluminum comes
with obviously the Apple watch charger
and the five watt charging brick now we
need our watch band if they didn't
launch the new ceramic this probably
would be the color that I would have
chosen I just love this little cute
little cover I'm gonna save this so
obviously put your Apple watch and hold
it near the camera setting up the new
Apple watch on the new iPhone so one of
the new things in this Apple watch is it
has an always-on display which is great
because I think that you guys are very
familiar especially if you've used Apple
watches before of this gesture to
activate it so it's the raise to wake so
I'm enabling the emergency SOS another
thing that is new in this Apple watch is
you
use the emergency calling international
if you have the cellular enabled so it
looks like this is still sinking so I'm
going to let it think it said it'll give
me a notification when it's done and we
have a lot of new stuff to test out I
guess as soon as this gives me a
notification I'll be back and we'll be
in the relocation
I've been using the Apple watch now for
two days and I cannot stress enough how
much I love the always-on display
obviously it is the newest feature in
the Apple watch series five but it's
something that I didn't realize how much
I wanted until I have it I went hiking
this morning and that was the first time
that I got a chance to actually put this
Apple watch to use it's really fun to be
making this video because the Apple
watch has helped me personally get in
shape I love hearing all the stories of
how the Apple watch has changed people's
lives and I am definitely one of them so
the Apple watch is definitely one of the
best devices out there for tracking
these types of things there are others
so whatever it is that you decide to use
if it helps you get motivated and keep
yourself accountable then use that but
for me it is the Apple watch it's also
been crazy to see the progress that you
make because you have all of that data
with you I just tested out the new
compass feature which is really cool
because they'll tell you what direction
you're going it'll show your elevation
if you hear longitude and latitude and
it'll also be able to orientate you when
you're in maps which is pretty awesome
especially if you're using cellular and
you don't have your phone on you I also
love being able to keep track of my
heart rate because I know that I'm
starting to feel a little exhausted or
something and I can check my heart rate
I know that yes my heart rate is high so
the feeling that I'm having is
completely normal
[Music]
so watch both the Apple watch is being
able to track your heart health so being
able to take an ECG always have
consistent data I mean I have the health
data for the past like five years that
I've been wearing an Apple watch so it
takes about 30 seconds and with that
it'll give you what the rhythm of your
heart is so I have the sinus rhythm so
it takes about 30 seconds and it'll give
you a result here and then it'll send a
PDF to your phone and that's where I
think the new health research app is
gonna be really cool so basically you
can opt in to share your data so
researchers and analysts can go through
all of that data and make sense of it in
the latest update to the watch OS they
have a decibel meter pretty neat I
haven't tried this out yet so you guys
are witnessing the first time trying
this I have to be really really annoying
and loud so I'm probably going to turn
this volume down then you guys can watch
on the decibel meter it's a repeated
long-term exposure to that sound could
give you hearing damage
[Music]
namaste hope you guys enjoyed that fake
yoga workout for the sake of filming
this video one of the things that I love
so much is peloton I have the treadmill
I did a video about that a while ago I
probably should do a follow-up because
one of the things that I love so much
about the peloton treadmill is the fact
that peloton has a digital app they have
all kinds of classes they have outdoor
running just regular running cycling
strength training yoga even have
meditation stretching and they also have
a really cool boot camp this will give
you a combination of running and also
strength training exercises so I have
any huge fan of this app I love it
especially when I'm traveling I always
have something with me on the go I could
do yoga I could do my running classes
even if I don't have a treadmill let's
go to some more fake working out for the
signals
[Music]
[Applause]
we're at the climbing gym now and I'm so
excited to do some taxes here with the
Apple watch and of course have seen out
the ultralight
because Jenna took a bunch of the
earlier
that Jennifer now there she is sue zoom
do a zoom there she goes
[Music]
business climate ended upon so much
Tyler is on his way up and that's the
climbing test of the new Apple watch on
display I have two new Apple watch bands
to check out this is Clementine and this
is one of the new sport loops this is
the pomegranate sport loop the new sport
loops have this little contrasting band
along the edges this looks nice let's
put this on I love the sport loops this
looks awesome I love that they have the
new two-tone so when you put it on you
have two different colors this is
actually exactly the color that I'm
wearing I promise you I do not play in
this even though you would think that I
did this is pretty much my shirt you can
cut the perforated holes and everything
that's what it looks like next to the
pink sand and next to my current one
well thank you guys so much for watching
I love the Apple watch and when I say
that this thing actually did get me to
start working out again like Jenna come
here
can you just can you just let them know
what a lazy bum I was like it was bad
picture a potato and picture that potato
on a couch picture the face of Justine
on that potato on the couch guess what I
have a face of me on a potato thanks to
row potato is completely done let me
show you off what I got ready okay oh I
know look good I'm so glad you got the
shoes
the only time that I would like get off
the couch or anything was to go do work
or get ice cream you were having like
two ice creams a day because most three
years ago I still eat ice cream and
still lead a lot of snacks but at least
I'm active for sure remember that first
hike that we went on the Temescal one
which I did today and I was kind of
flashing back to the time that your
heart rate was like 190 are you okay I
said no and I cannot wait for you to get
yours because the always on display like
look we see you just turn off wait does
it blur text messages well yeah it does
look at that oh look at this
blurred okay I think that's neat on my
video hey why well you guys for watching
I will see you guys soon in my next
video bye
[Music]